oui le problème qui se pose aujourd'hui
en russie et dans d'autres républiques
de l'ex union soviétique et
dramatiquement simple ces centres
continue de fonctionner car on ne peut
pas faire autrement pour des raisons
strictement financières et les pays
occidentaux seront sans aucun doute mis
à contribution en attendant sur le
terrain certaines familles reviennent
bien que la conduite de contamination
soit toujours présente et les victimes
de cette catastrophe n'ont toujours pas
oublié
c'est terriblement de moscou notre
correspondant dominique derda nicolaï
shalimov n'oubliera jamais tchernobyl
dans un lointain cimetière de la
banlieue de moscou où il vient se
recueillir devant les tombes de ceux
qu'il appelle des anges les liquidateurs
comme on dit en russe mort irradiés dans
les jours qui suivirent la catastrophe
pour s'être approché un peu trop près du
réacteur en feu nicolas shalimov a passé
trois mois à tchernobyl sur les soixante
personnes qui travaillaient avec lui
quinze sont mortes depuis de ce qu'il
considère comme son devoir de soldat il
a retiré ni gloire ni fortune les
compensations aucun des anciens de
tchernobyl navale ou en version on a
bien des lois mais ne sont pas appliqués
à prévenir chez une carte qui nous
permet de voyager gratuitement dans les
transports en commun à l'exception des
taxis et je reçois l'équivalent de 3
salaire minimum par an 3 salaire minimum
c'est-à-dire 180 francs au total
huit ans après tchernobyl fonctionne
toujours deux des quatre unités sont
encore en service la centrale devait
être fermée avant 20 93 mais le
parlement ukrainien en a décidé
autrement elle fournit encore 7 % des
besoins de l'ukraine en électricité
l'équivalent de plus de 4 millions de
tonnes de pétrole par an et l'ukraine
est un pays pauvre elle n'a pas les
moyens dit ses dirigeants de se passer
de tchernobyl pourtant de l'avis des
experts le danger menace 36 incidents
mineurs l'an dernier 2 encore la semaine
passée et le sarcophage de béton qui
recouvre l'unité numéro 4 donnerait déjà
des signes de faiblesse nul ne sait
combien de temps il pourra encore tenir
à cela il faut ajouter le départ vers la
russie voisine ou vers la capitale de
nombreux techniciens qualifiés mais trop
mal payé bref rien de bien rassurant
dans tout cela
les autorités ukrainiennes sont
évidemment consciente des risques si
elles maintiennent la centrale en
activité c'est bien sûr pour des raisons
économiques c'est aussi une manière très
directe de dire à leurs voisins inquiets
si vous voulez que nous fermions la
centrale de tchernobyl donnez nous les
moyens de le faire